let me let me ask you um we have a lot
of ground to cover and very little time
to do it
um there's an election in 33 days
uh right you know i went through a lot
of things and
you know i don't know um we always say
the words
this is the land of the free and the
home of the brave and uh
mark is right if you look at the debate
with paul ryan years ago
joe biden um interrupted a lot fought a
lot was
was but from all my interviews with you
you don't apologize for
fighting to take out the caliphate or
solomonia or
l baghdadi or the al qaeda league leader
in in yemen
you don't seem to mind to fight to get
the money for the wall or fight for
lower taxes
or or to go out and and fight for energy
independence or
fight for the justices you promised you
put on the supreme court
um some people say well maybe the
president shouldn't have fought so hard
in the debate
how do you respond to them well i have
to do it because i know a lot of people
said look he was losing his cha
you know his his uh if you look at what
he did he was probably or possibly
losing
that coherence that everybody talks
about because he's a mess let's face it
he's a mess
now i could have waited but he was
saying so many lies
that i figured it was just better to
bring it up as he sang it because it was
just lie
after lie after lie and so i do it as he
said it i would
criticize him and i think it was
effective if you look at the polls i
mean
almost all the polls the poll people the
polls
say that i won the hispanics they have
me close to 70
to 28 because they're strong people that
was the telemundo pole there was a wgn
poll that had you at 61
um yeah well by the way i mean i would
have i would have preferred letting him
catch himself because
because he can't issue a full statement
practically but at the same time
on the assumption that he does he's
going on and on with lie after lie so i
had to
correct those lies as they came up too
many to go back
and get she didn't have enough we didn't
have enough paper
too many to go and get and i don't know
i think it was a very effective frankly
i'd like to
leave the same format i like the format
what if they changed they're talking
about the debate commission
asking uh talking about changing the
rules they're already rules agreed to
what is your reaction if they try to do
that
well this is the rules that were agreed
to but you know i think it would be very
bad you remember with hillary clinton
they
modulated my mic and they actually
apologized for it but they molly
they modulated my mic so when i looked
at her
and my mic turned off we're way down and
i said what's going on over here
they actually issued an apology so we're
dealing with very tricky people here
but i think you remember that very well
they modulated
my mic and they say i won all of the
debates so i was in 1617 debates they
say i won all of the debates i like this
format
but at the same time you know he's got a
he's got to be truthful and
by the way a number of people brought up
today sean that he was the one that
interrupted me he started off with three
major interruptions
long before i started doing it to him
by the way i want to point out tonight
uh i know the first lady
melania trump the white house is
pink tonight in honor of breast cancer
awareness
month and she wrote that as one nation
we remember the precious lives loss
pray to bring um comfort and strength to
those battling
uh the disease by the way my my mom and
life had very advanced stage
cancer breast cancer double mastectomy
chemotherapy radiation she survived it
but barely
so it is an important thing one in seven
women
can get this it's very scary let me ask
you about
joe biden will not answer the question
about packing the court yeah chuck
schumer said
last night that everything is on the
table
that means statehood for d.c statehood
for puerto rico
ending the legislative filibuster and
some democrats have even talked about
moving for a constitutional amendment to
end the electoral college
joe biden says that it's a trick a
donald trump trick
to tell the american people if he'll
stack the courts or or
do any of these things your response
well i went after him on that and i said
are you going to stack the court i also
said are you going to say the word
law and order he wouldn't say him he
then said law and order was safety and
justice
or something but i said to him that but
you know we need law and order in our
country and
the democrat cities are falling to
pieces with this whole
with these people running them but uh
stacking the courts
they could have many justices they want
to put many because we've been beating
them
and we have the nine justices and we
have a great new one going on
but now what they want to do is they
want to put many additional
justices on the supreme court so that
they can
it's sort of like you're losing the game
and you start cheating
but they want to put many they are i
mean they're doing it with the ballots
they're doing it with the supreme court
and it's a very sad thing but they are
uh they are looking to stack
the court and they are also going to add
two or three new states i heard
guam and two others that you mentioned
as you know
that would give them six automatic
senate seats automatic
no chance it would be very unfair and 20
something
congressional seats so that's what they
want to do
so if you if you give them what they
want we really have a one-party system
you can never catch up
so they'll be talking about anywhere
from four to six senators
republicans can't win those states
although i've been better to puerto rico
than any other president i've given them
a lot of help but if you take a look at
what's happening they're not good to
puerto rico
but i've been good to puerto rico i have
a great relationship to puerto rico
but they're looking for uh statehood a
lot of
puerto ricans don't want statehood
they're doing better the way it is now
frankly but they want to uh and
you've been seeing this this has been
taking place they want to put
two or three states so they want to have
they want to have 53
right 53 what's the flag going to look
like right john what's the flag going to
look like they want to have 53 or 52
depending on what they do i guess they
could probably do even more than that we
have islands all over the place why
don't they go for
the whole ball game so it's a very very
sad thing for our country
very very sad thing and in all fairness
to
mitch he did not want to do the nuclear
option
and i disagreed because i said they're
going to do it it turned out that they
are but but
he's a legitimate guy he's not he wasn't
going to do the nuclear option because
he thought it was bad for our country so
i understood that i didn't go
wild but i did say it would be good to
do it because they're going to do it
so it's a very sad thing so you're going
to have
two or three more states added you're
going to have
four or six uh senators added 100
democrat 100 you're going to have maybe
20
congressional candidates or districts
added
and it's really a horrible thing it's
going to be very unfair you're going to
end up having a one-party system in the
united states so people want to stop
that
you got to vote against the democrats by
the way some news broke earlier this
evening
uh hope hicks who's worked for you for a
long time has tested positive for
coronavirus um obviously our prayers are
with her and by the way
everybody uh that is as you call taking
gotten this
invisible enemy uh do you have any
update on her and
where are we with therapeutics where are
we with the vaccine so she did test
positive i just heard about this she
tested positive
she's a hard worker a lot of masks she
wears masks a lot but she tested
positive then i just went out with a
test i'll see what you know because we
spent a lot of time in the first lady
just went out with a test
also so whether we quarantine or whether
we have it i don't know you know it's
very hard when you're with soldiers when
you're with
uh airmen you're with the marines and
i'm with and the police officers i'm
with them so much
and when they come over you it's very
hard to say stay back stay back you know
it's a tough kind of a situation it's a
terrible thing
so um i just went for a test and we'll
see what happens i mean
who knows but you know hope very well
she's fantastic and she's done a great
job
but it's very very hard uh when you are
with people
from the military or for law enforcement
and they come over to you and they
they want to hug you and they want to
kiss you because we really have done a
good job for them and
you get close and things happen i was
surprised to hear with hope but she's a
very warm person
with them and she she knows there's a
risk but she's
uh young and i just i just went out for
a
test they just do it it'll come back
later i guess
and the first lady also because we spend
a lot of time with hope and others
so we'll see what happens but uh where
are we with therapeutics and with the
vaccine
you have to treat our people great you
can't just say stay away stay away they
come up to you there's such
love with what we've done for them and
there's such love and you have to treat
our people great
uh i think the vaccines are coming uh
quickly
i do think it's somewhat political
they'd like to do it even the drug
companies they
you know they've dealt with these people
a long time i think they'd like to do it
after the election
even if it's a couple of days but the
fact is the vaccines are coming out
the therapeutics are coming out and
they're coming out really good
regeneron and others other companies are
great
eli lilly uh so you know we'll have to
see the
the survival rate is so much better now
than it was
you've seen those numbers i guess 95 or
something like that better
so what to see i mean i'll i'll get my
test back either tonight or tomorrow
morning
but i you know i spent a lot of time
with hope and so does the first lady
and she's tremendous i was a little
surprised but she's she's a very warm
person she has a hard time
when soldiers and law enforcement come
up comes up to her you know
she wants to treat them great not say
stay away i can't get near you it's a
it's a very very tough disease
let me let me ask you this question you
have talked a lot about
um the issue of voter fraud and
by the way this this was just breaking
tonight as we're coming on the air
uh that the trump campaign is suing
philadelphia over maryland voting
offices we had a hundred thousand
ballots in trouble the heritage
foundation identified 1285 cases of
recent
voter fraud including nearly a thousand
convictions on the
on the issues uh we've saw the the trump
ballots military ballots and a waste
paper bastic
basket in in pennsylvania
we had you know people being mailed
absentee ballots and
we had voter we had a criminal
conviction in new jersey
uh attempted to bribe voters with
mail-in ballots
project veritas came out with the tape
there was a case in florida there's been
cases all over colorado florida
texas um and everyone knows it john
how do we how do we have voter integrity
and this idea that hillary clinton
talked about you accepting the results
of the election hillary said under no
circumstances should joe
biden ever concede the election joe said
the other night he would uh
under the right circumstances do you
really foresee a problem and
these last minute changes that are being
made
i i mean to me it's incalculable how
that then
impacts the election what are your
thoughts well new york they lost a
hundred thousand ballots were
sent out wrong the envelopes were wrong
the names were wrong everything was
wrong
so they said oh that's okay we'll send
out a new hundred thousand okay let's
assume they get it right what happens to
the hundredth accent that they sent out
they're going to be sent back by
somebody
and it's going to be a fraud this is a
terrible thing that's happening to our
country and
you know the only one that knows it
better than you and i and other people
is the democrats they know it they know
it they're smart
but i'll tell you the big hope is that
we have great federal judges
and we have a lot of cases in front of
these federal judges and
i think they're really talented very
smart and
i think that we're going to do very well
because no judge how about this
uh the election ends on november 3rd but
they're giving like certain states the
right to go another week so that means
we're not going to know because you know
they're big states
that means we're not going to know the
election for another week and then if
there's fraud then there's going to be a
lot of
you know and there will be just take a
look at new york take a look at
the ones the the ballots that were
thrown into a garbage can and they all
had the trump name on it
they were military ballots they were
thrown into a garbage can
the ones that were on a tray and they
were thrown into a creek or a river
it's a terrible thing and if you look at
carol and maloney
what they did to that guy that ran
against her is a disgrace
that's in new york and that's only for a
congressional race
they have no idea where the votes are
where the ballots are this is going to
be all over this is in virginia this is
in new jersey
it's a very very sad thing and hopefully
we can win by
a lot because i have no doubt that
they're going to be doing
a number i have no doubt about it and
the press knows that too you know they
act so
so sacrosanct they actually oh
it's so terrible he's talking about our
democracy
they know what's going on it's really a
shame if
if the other side did this you would see
everybody would be arrested put in jail
you have to see what's going on but the
good news is we just got a very good
decision in rhode island
great decision we have some great
decisions coming down you have to have
the votes in by november 3rd
you have to have it signed you have to
have it certified
they have to guarantee the certification
i mean
in nevada sean they don't want to have
any certification of a signature
just do a signature and they don't want
to have certification
i think that you don't even i think you
don't even have to sign it
and the governor is a very political
person it's a
it's a ridiculous thing and we're going
to win nevada on a fair basis
but it's very hard when they send
millions of ballots out and then they
cheat
uh let me ask you we learned this week
and this is something we broke a lot of
news in the last three and a half years
not really gotten a lot of credit for it
turns out we were right all along
that the obama administration knew in
2016
that they knew hillary was attempting to
tie
you to russia to get away and distract
from her
subpoenaed emails we also learned
that now james comey along with rod
rosenstein along with sally h knowing
what they know now never would have
signed the fisa applications that
denied constitutional rights to carter
page to spy on your campaign your
transition
team and your presidency uh comey had
amnesia on the rest of it
but we also learned that christopher
steele's source
and that was the bulk of data andrew
mccabe said no
no no no uh christopher steele
files at hillary dossier there would be
no no pfizer warrants
we now know that all of it
was from a guy that the our own fbi knew
to be a russian
operative for 10 years we don't have a
lot of time your reaction all this well
it's a scam they spied on our campaign
they got caught
the only sad thing is nothing's
happening with them and they're a bunch
of crooks
they spied in our campaign they got
caught they tried to take they tried to
do a coup
and they got caught now we got to see
what's going to happen it's time to move
this is ridiculous okay this is
ridiculous it's so sad we caught them
spying on our campaign never happened
before
spied before and after and it never
happened before and i watched comey he
couldn't remember anything but he's
writing all these books they're guilty
as hell
they should all be in jail okay you know
it and i know it they should all be in
jail
and it's disgraceful it's a disgrace to
our country
if they don't go to jail hillary clinton
got caught comey got caught they all got
caught
and biden by the way mentioned the logan
act that was a big part of it
and obama too it's a disgrace what's
happened
a disgrace and they should do something
about it
they can't let this just go on at
infinitum
they should do something about it let me
ask you very quickly here
this selection is in 33 days what is
in the 45 seconds we have left
you've gone through things you want to
do the economy
law and order safety security and a
vaccine are those your three top things
that you want
well it is i mean it is but we've
already rebuilt
the military two and a half trillion
dollars it's the strongest military in
the world by far
we have weapons the likes of which
nobody even comes close to
and so we've done that we've cut taxes
at a record level we've
cut uh if you look at regulations we've
cut more regulations than any president
in in by the end of this year in your
view well
i think you're going to see some great
numbers just two days before because
you're going to have the third quarter
come out just before the election
i think you're going to be up anywhere
from 22 to 35
in gdp and if that's the case that's
bigger than any
economic rebound in history so i think
that'll be good let's see what happens
but
those numbers are coming out sometime
prior to sometime prior to
november 3rd which is the election all
right mr president
33 days the american people the ultimate
jury thank you for being with us
thank you very much john thank you